let me ask you guys a question so here's
a question for you okay
uh uh what will make you
vote for
biden okay what will make you vote for
biden what has to be and for you the
question is what will make you vote for
trump okay hear me out where i'm going
here so just think about for whoever
that voted against biden or whoever that
voted against trump you got to ask the
question at what level will you vote for
the opposition okay so for me if you
look at aoc here's how aoc works there's
a part i relate to aoc this is why i
relate to uoc
aoc do you think she supports what biden
is doing right now no she's actively
we're going to talk about that here in a
minute it's absolutely berserk she's not
happy with biden right the aoc the
ilhanomar all those guys during the
verse
when it comes down to voting who's she
going to vote for trump no or she's
going to vote for by no no okay so now
watch this year watch this here for me
okay
i don't like uh uh half the stuff that
happens where the divisiveness and
constant creating new enemies that maybe
trump takes the route and he's
constantly going after him right but
when it comes down to it i'm gonna vote
for whoever is for lower taxes lower
regulation
eliminating censorship for me so so
that's where it goes to okay here's what
i'm gonna go as a registered independent
for the last ten years this is where i'm
going i'm a libertarian we've not yet
seen a solid joe jorgensen when i sat
down with ron paul and we did the
interview and i were there together and
i think it was in houston when we did
the interview it was incredible by the
time you're done you're like this guy
makes a lot of sense but the question is
at what point will somebody in your
party come out were you going to
i'm voting for the person you would
least vote for in this instance it's
biden and trump i'm gonna go with you
first so who needs to be on your side of
the aisle which is let's just say
the left to center left who needs to be
on your side of the house we're going to
say you know what screw it um
i'm not going to vote for anybody on the
left i'm going to go vote for trump
would anybody make you vote for him
repeat you're saying okay would anybody
be able to convince me let's just say no
no let's just say the the person that's
running on your side is uh beto it's uh
mcconaughey it's aoc it's
a mansion it's whoever who would need to
be the nominee on the left for you to
say i'm sitting this one out i'm
actually going to vote for trump on this
one
see
maybe the bigger question is would i
vote for a republican no no this
specific because i would i would vote
for republicans but this but not a trump
so this specific question i'm asking you
like for them if i say clinton they're
gonna say yeah no problem voting for
bill clinton to this specific example it
is biden and it is trump the reason why
i'm using this example as a following
reason
is
biden's probably the least democratic
president republicans would want okay
probably worse than carter okay but many
republicans were okay with uh uh bill
clinton so and on the democratic side
trump is probably the least candidate
you would want on the opposite side
maybe you would be comfortable with a
reagan hypothetically right versus a
trump what i'm asking is who needs to be
on your side of the aisle to say
i think it's crossed the line i'm
probably gonna go vote for trump who
would it be
you're saying running against trump
pose the question specifically i've
asked four times
i've asked this thing four times did you
get my question or no there's literally
nobody that you would detest so much on
the democratic side that would make you
be like nah you know what trump said
like anyone elon omar was no no no i
don't know anything anything on the ten
percent left so who would make you say
i'm gonna vote i'm actually gonna
support trump if the candidate was is
was as equally as divisive as trump if
my whole thing is
we all like look at us we can all get
along we can all have dinner we can all
have lunch we can all get along we're
america okay he's a marine he's a
talented guy he's a businessman i'm in
fight like we we all have like christian
man of the club what i'm saying a jewish
christian like
we're not as divided as the media or
politics want us to i don't disagree
like what we need in this country is
someone who's going to go back to the
question
can we all just sit down and have a
basic
niceness towards each other let me know
trump doesn't doesn't make that a
question at all for the fifth
time this is where the audience gets
upset sometimes because you don't answer
questions no matter what you say you're
not going to convince me to vote for
[ __ ] trump so
whatever by the way whatever way
by the way i'm not going to say you guys
fyi that's when you lose people brother
that's when you lose people because i'm
not willing no no no no no let me
explain to you why you lose people there
if you're saying an aoc or uh or ill on
omar i'm not interested in that either
this is this is where your argument
loses because you lose credibility
because you're not willing to succumb to
trump you ask me a question and you say
a guy like an alex jones is the face of
the right and i got and biden on the
other side i'm probably gonna say i have
no clue what this guy's gonna do i'm
gonna have to consider that vote but to
you it's hard to have logic to say
here's what would make me say i'm going
to go this way because even right now
like give you an idea kodak blew the
other day tweets out i don't know if you
guys saw kodak blues uh kodak black
kodak black kodak blue kodak black said
come down here pompano yeah he just
tweets out the other day did you see the
tweet here's what kodak said the other
day he said
uh uh uh uh it's not coming out come on
kai oh
sorry about it okay kodak black sends a
tweet and he says you guys wanna it's
not working for you you gotta be kidding
me it's just the basics
adam how much how much of your decision
making process goes with uh
percentage-wise goes with voting for
policy versus the person i'm just
curious that's exactly where my next
question was going
the i mean i think it's 50 50. i mean
maybe even more persona than policy more
i don't i don't i don't know how much
does policy
how many people actually get down and
dirty into people's policies i think
people are what their platform is yeah i
think most people are one issue voter or
two issue voter and they they what's
your what's your number one issue
see i don't have family i don't have
kids so i'm not as issue oriented i
so what were you gonna change your the
the name of your uh twitter handle to be
or a centrist
or a synergist
synergist yeah that's what this country
needs it's so it's not the question
though but that's the point but that's
not the question though
this is the guy that's saying we need a
synergy that's what i'm saying okay the
story is not the same keep doubling down
on trump doubling down trump imagine if
we had trump president again let me
imagine we don't have trump president
again we have someone that actually that
the entire country actually likes
whether it's on the left or right then
there can't be a reasonable conversation
with you why can't there be a reason
because i just asked you a reasonable
question and you can't give a reason
it's been eight minutes i'm moving the
story i'm gonna go to you so who needs
to be on your side for you to say i
would consider a biden uh biden actually
was probably my my uh
third or fourth choice out of the
democratic primary i'm much happier that
biden got in i thought that for sure
that they were going to try to shove
kamala harris down her throat
they still made it's not too late not
too late
um you know as far as look i don't like
coercion
when when you get into the democratic
party and you get into the coercive
nature of what they are anybody who
increases wants you like what what aoc
what we talked about we talked about
this morning aoc is going after biden
for not being a dictator saying he has
unilateral powers to to uh do universal
health care to eliminate student debt to
to basic she wants the president united
states with the stroke of his pen
to completely and totally nationalize
entire executive order executive order
executive order and not just little
things yeah she wants essentially the
government through one stroke of the man
of one person's pen to nationalize
entire verticals of our of our
government and our economy
the fact that she's saying that and
she's lamenting the fact that he won't
be a dictator terrifies me because they
show their face so who would need to be
on the right for you to say i remember i
didn't vote for trump the first time i
get that that's why i'm asking you so
for you who is too far right on the
right i would have voted for tulsi
gabbard in a heartbeat i would have
voted for
uh back in the day remember joe
lieberman i liked joe lieberman back in
the interesting like joe lieberman i
thought bill clinton was a really really
when you talked about chris christie
when i when i was when i was with
christy
he was a synergist and cory booker
wasn't this far left socialist cory
booker and chris christie work like this
and they really did an unbelievable job
for the city of newark then i got on a
national scale and they had to go to the
extremes when i was younger right and
you guys are you know a little older
than me you guys remember the way to win
was to work towards the center
now the way to win seems to be to work
towards the extremes they are terrified
of their extremes i think it's because
there's no money anywhere else only the
crazy and the greedy donate money guys
normal everyday working americans
they're not donating their time they're
not out there volunteering they're not
out there marching lunatics are lunatics
are the ones that are filling the
streets all right so that's where the
political you can't run a campaign
without volunteers and money and they
have to go to the extremes to get this
and i think that's what's pulling off
you know what i like about van jones let
me tell you what i like about van jones
maybe that could be something for as an
inspiration for our buddy here okay
this is i'm a van jones fan and van
jones was a communist card holding guy
years ago when he first was
chosen to be part of uh obama's uh what
do you call it uh
uh administration within a week they
have to get him to be gone because the
guy was a former communist he supported
some of the principles of communism so
you have to resign well
do you remember when trump went out
there and he did what he did with uh uh
prison uh uh reform and it was something
that nobody had ever done and he came in
and he fixed it and he it was just
absolutely berserk and
uh uh and van jones if you guys don't
remember this can you click on van jones
trump prison reform picture was it okay
kardashian somehow oh she was in a big
way but but this is not even a kim story
this is about a van jones who hates
trump
okay who hates trump if you go to images
goes uh on images go to images and type
in the picture right there go the one to
the left the one to the left right there
can you click on it okay uh see if we
can make that bigger
all right see if you go a little closer
go a little closer
uh we can't play that can we so go back
and go to the uh uh go back and see if
we can find another picture
um
okay click on any one of those on the
bottom right there to uh to the right to
the right yeah go click on that one
let's just say sit down okay do you see
who's standing behind that lady with the
red jacket on who is that van jones who
is he he's a hardcore democrat you know
yeah but he went to that and you know
what he did on cnn that that pissed off
cuomo and everybody else he started
crying
he started crying he says because this
is the first time i've seen a president
be able to do something with prison
reform you know what that's called
that's called the synergist a synergist
is not somebody that no matter what the
guy cannot do anything right that's not
a synergist so if you're talking about
you wanting to be a synergist van jones
to me who him and i disagree on 80
of things politically i respect the [ __ ]
out of this position here this is what
we need fyi principal when it's when i
ask a question and here's what's said
when i ask a question so people ask me
and they'll say why do you interview so
many communists you know how many people
i've lost because i interview communists
do you know how many people go read the
comment section it's too bad though if
any any of the comments you know you see
what they say at the bottom i say i'm
actually trying to see where we agree
yeah where do we agree i want to
understand you to get an idea of where
we agree and then from that you say okay
okay i sat down with alex jones on 9 11
you and i were there that interview was
almost done with you remember when he
started biting the apple we thought it's
going to be done when he's going to walk
off the set yeah but we had the
conversation and what was the
conversation about you pressed the hell
out of him i pressed the hell out of him
and he was unhappy about it so it wasn't
like well hey alex so tell me what a
fantastic job you're you're pissing a
lot of people off on the other side this
is so cool bro the guy wanted to leave
he was not happy with us no he he his
his handler was like
his hand
that you're interviewing these people do
you say
that's a good point actually one million
percent okay so you've you've one
million percent you've said hey good
point two communists okay exactly yes so
so go with me now here so on individual
points you said okay check for the karl
marx
but at any point no matter how many
points this guy's made is there any
chance that you're going to believe in
communism and socialism did you just
your mind the answer is no right but did
you just see what you're doing do you
see what you're doing these two
analogies have nothing to do with each
other i didn't make an analogy and i'm
asking you a question you're making a
point right without having answered the
question yet so for you the question
that was asked on your end you can't
answer because to you
i see i see what you did there i see
what you did there you're i was trying
to make a vow to know in your eyes in
your eyes a man can't do anything right
that's not pat that's not what i said
wait a minute i said when i said it i
asked
i will give trump credit on certain
things i like what he did in the middle
east i like what he did on deregulation
but that doesn't mean i'm going to be a
trump fan or vote for him do you
actually you said you wouldn't you've
agreed with certain socialist points
socialist this question no because i see
what you did there and i was good that
was a good tactic did what there
explained to me what did you like i
tried to make the same analogy that you
made for me and and in my mind do you
realize
we've asked you six times the same
question okay so i'll be very surprised
either you say either you answer to have
credibility to get a response from me
yes sir or you don't if you don't answer
you have no credibility here's my
discussion here's that's simple are
there things that trump has done well
yes that's that's the question though so
let's skip it if you don't want to
answer the question i wouldn't vote for
trump i said it a million different
things not the question the question is
who on your side of the aisle needs to
represent for you to say i would
actually entertain an oppose this is a
regular conversation you're saying how
bad does the democratic candidate have
to be seven times the same question
basically would you vote for every time
omar or donald trump let me ask you i
vote for george organ
serious question how much of that is
social equity your you know your friends
your family the people that you
associate with god forbid they ever
found out i don't give two shits you
know
seriously honestly clearly i don't give
a [ __ ] about what i don't know what
people think how i vote i don't care
you're you're half my friend's circle
half my friends think that i'm a
a uh i actually i'm not a
guy because i'm on this channel let me
have two people think i'm a communist uh
i don't give a [ __ ] there's a person
i'll explain why i asked that question
it wasn't an accusation it's a serious
question it's fine there's a person very
very close to me that i absolutely love
who staunch staunch far left
basically her whole life okay uh came up
through academia and made her career in
it and over the course of the last 20
months
she's now
moving in a direction i actually got a
text from her she was like she was like
uh you've been right about a lot of
things it pains me to say that and i'm
like one more time i got a screenshot
that
now she can't
be vocal about
what she believes to be true that's the
hardest part
she believes she'll be ostracized in her
community
her friends will ostracize her she's
seen cancer culture up close and
personal she is literally a prisoner of
and what's her community though
uh her community is academics okay so
she's in the liberal northeast academic
community i'm assuming correct yeah when
you insulate yourself into a bubble
that's what happens whether you're on
the left or the right
if you're i see this is where i got to
disagree it might even be worse than the
left i got yeah i got to disagree
because my experience has been
especially in the entertainment industry
people on the right will have no problem
hanging out with people on the left they
have no problem hiring people on the
left they have they have no problem
being disagreed with and there was those
those instances whereas
the the more progressive
quote unquote the situation is the the
job site is or the environment is they
tolerate no blasphemy yeah but that's a
recent thing bro nobody wouldn't hire
you
10 years ago because you liked george w
bush i hear you it would have been
irrelevant because of trump what's
interesting about that is that i
actually didn't like george bush i
didn't like dick cheney and now dick and
liz cheney are pro-biden now all of a
sudden the progressives are on the side
of the warhawk republicans it's the
establishment
it's a weird situation but you say it's
it's a a recent thing that's why we're
talking about it because this
is not passing the smell test this is
not an okay thing so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye
[Music]